[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يطوف رمضان على الفصول الاربعه مره واحده
كل 32 سنه ويرجع ذلك الى ان شهر رمضان
يتبع نظام السنه القمريه والتي مدتها
354 يوما والفصول تتبع نظام السنه الشمسيه
والتي مدتها 365 يوما والفارق بينهما 11
يوما تقريبا بمعنى ان السنه القمريه
تتقهقر عن السنه الميلاديه شهرا واحدا كل
ثلاث سنوات وفي هذه السنه شهر رمضان يعيش
في اخر الربيع وبعد ثلاث سنوات سيعيش
رمضان في اخر الشتاء ورمضان ربيع الفقراء
كيف اقول انك ربيع القلب وانك اكثر العالم
طه الروح ورحابه جابك الله في زحام العمر
كنك دعوه ام وافقت
وقت استجابه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في هذه السنه
1444 و 45 و46 سنصوم في الربيع ومن بدايه
عام
1447 و 48 وتسعه واربعين وخمسين وواحد
وخمسين و52 سنصومه في فاصل الشتاء بمعنى
انه هالانسان يصوم فصلا واحدا ثلاث مرات
بحياته يلا التوبه لا تغبطن اهل بيت سرهم
زمن فسوف يطرقهم بالهم والحزن يعيرهم كل
دنياهم وينهب ماء اعارهم بيد الافات
والمحن
[موسيقى]